open up for questions as well so let's
have you guys think about questions are
beers there are there other thoughts
that you think are important to address
as well no I think I mean I think you've
got a general idea stimuli he doing that
awesome awesome okay cool and give us
just one moment we have a wireless mic
we want to make sure to capture the
audio from you from your questions and
we're coming we're coming at you with
their time by the way I have to be out
of here by about 9:00 but that's an hour
from now don't worry if we have to wait
a few seconds for the microphone to come
along okay so this is a probably
predictable question you get often which
is if things don't change in terms of
funding and you know Cal coves doing
their thing and you're doing your thing
what what is your projection of when
that moment is going to be with twelve
people stand up and say we think it's a
solvable problem so um well first of all
the funding is changing quite fast
you know the whole correctly the
industry the questions they startups and
so on spin out so our projects even
three years ago that just had not begun
so this is trending gratifyingly fire so
that's a really big bit of good news oh
but to answer your question directly
um how soon are we going to get to that
tipping point yeah I think it could be
awfully soon
you see what's the question how soon
we're going to get to the therapy being
available for humans then I have to give
you know a terribly speculative answer
and I do give an answer I think that you
know we've got a 50/50 chance of going
there in 20 years from now 10% chance at
least that it could be more than hundred
years if we had a lot of new problems
but 50% times is quite enough to be
worth waiting for so that's all good but
we're very unlikely to get there in less
than 15 years but for the tipping point
that I was talking about in terms of
public opinion the criterion that one
has to evaluate is how fragile the Pro
aging trance actually is right now in
other words how tiny the amount of
progress would need to be the amount of
positiveness that the experts would have
to be expressing in order for the dam to
break and honestly I am having a hard
time putting a good number on that I
think that I mean I thought about this a
bit obviously but honestly I'm terrified
it could happen next year you know it
could happen awfully sir if you ask me a
50/50 probability my best guess would be
around five years from now pretty small
amount of progress and this is
absolutely not to do with the funding
thing you mentioned this is in the
because of those kind of timeframe don't
really make much difference so yeah and
could be a lot less yeah yeah I am I
think that it's very likely indeed I
would say yet 90% that within 10 years
we will reach a point where it becomes
essentially just a pragmatic even from a
pure master invested interest
perspective funding perspective to those
gerontologist now even though those
people will still be the you know the
dinosaur basic scientist types who
really aren't thinking in terms you know
who is spending their time making sure
that they continue to be able to approve
each other's grant applications you know
yeah those people even they will come to
the conclusion that it just is riskier
to continue to be commercially banned
over here yeah so my father's father
died when he was 32 from heart disease
my dad currently is in his mid-70s and
is absolutely obsessed with anti-aging
culture and learning more about the
science behind it so he wants to ask
this is me you know asking for him what
could you do today to extend longevity
right like what is their action what
what is actually actionable at small and
besides yeah this question all the time
and it is the fairest question because
the fact is I have to tell the truth
there is nothing you can do today other
than writing
check and and even if you do it probably
not going to help you if you're over 70
you know so I have to just get people to
[ __ ] pay attention to the fact of
their kids matter you know and so the
little live it won't include your own
but yeah I mean fact is you know there's
all manner of things out there right now
very experimental things are you know we
might not be too far away from things
that could actually make a bit of a
difference but what we really care about
things that make enough difference to
buy you enough time to make good to get
the next thing you know the thing that I
feel longevity escape velocity I you
know we're we're good few years away
from that so two questions one is how
long do you think you can expand life
and the second one is what I've heard
you saying is really about stem-cell
implantation and is there something else
or is it just implanting stem cells and
hoping they regenerate and then after a
period of time you do it again and again
so well certainly well first of all I
can totally take the word hope out of
what you're saying we we do science you
know we obviously hope that our science
moves faster than otherwise but by the
time it gets to you it won't be heard
anymore so the purpose of all of these
regenerative therapies including the
stem cell ones is to repair the body in
whatever way if needed and there's a lot
of different types of repair that are
needed now the details of the
implementation do vary a lot there will
be some cases where we can put self in I
think basically a one-off will just
never need to do it again or at least
not for
long long time there'll be other cases
where it'll be nine eed to be done i
briefed every couple of years we could
it'll be a different kind of therapy
that now with fixing a different kind of
damage and of course that may be
improved over time either in terms of
the frequency may because in lower
frequency or in terms of the convenience
so like for a couple moving from surgery
to an injection so it's fine for it to
be every year rather than every ten
years things like that lots of these
little details well our case-by-case and
most of them are not clear at all to
answer the first part of your question
there is no limit this is this contact
the phrase I used a moment ago in
response to the previous question which
I shall elaborate on because a lot of
you probably haven't heard it
I can't this concept about 15 years ago
called longevity escape velocity and
what arises from is the fact that the
therapies which are going to work and
I've already explained are going to be
rejuvenation therapies that do not
simply slow down the rate at which the
body creates damage they actually repair
pre-existing damage in the body that
means that if you take something like
let's say 60 and you fix them up then
even if you're doing the fixing up
rather imperfectly you're going to buy
some time let's suppose you do it so
well that by the time they're 90
they've only got the same amount of
damage that they had when they were
biologically sick when they were 60
right look if you fixed a lot of the
damage did not all of it now if you
think about it the amount of damage that
they had may be the same if they heard
what they were 60 but the type of damn
it won't be the curve of course the type
of damage will be the stuff that the
therapy done work on good at the
intersection but you've had 30 yet to
improve the therapies or we have are you
so that means that the therapies we can
apply to that 90 year old is
biologically fixed it with a second time
will be better ones ones that can
actually work on some of again not all
but some of the damage that the first
therapy didn't work on and that means we
can rejuvenate the same people so they
won't be biologically 60 to the third
time until they let's say
chronologically 150 and so on we do what
I've called longevity escape velocity
the rate at which the minimum rate at
which we need to improve the
comprehensiveness the approximation to
perfection of these therapies in order
to stay one step ahead of the problem
and to repair damage faster than time is
passing I believe that once we get the
first generation of these therapies the
ones that I think we probably only give
the first 20 or 30 years of extension of
life working what those are the ones
we're already working to develop okay
once we get those working which is what
I said I think could be you know 20
years from now then we're done yeah we
will easily be at whatever the escape
velocity we will easily be able to
continue to improve their therapies
faster than we need does we'll come back
here a second does it doesn't do do it
does us getting our genomic sequence the
microbiome analyzed do those things help
you understand us for when we need your
therapy genomic sequence is always
useful for a lot of things but I don't
think it's going to be all that useful
in terms of the application of these
therapies the use of genomics right now
and also epigenomics of course a below
mix and these very personalized data
sets are very helpful right now in the
development of stopgaps in the
development of drugs that kind of do a
little bit you know it so maybe postpone
this or that thing and maybe also they
will give us some insights into the
Quickie of the shortest route towards
developing therapies of the sort that we
actually work on but when the therapies
exist they will not be very important
for the reasons like spot that earlier
that we all have the same time it's
active damage what go by them is a very
fashionable area right now and rightly
so
it's you know it's an area biology
that's very poorly understood I don't
personally believe that manipulation of
the microbiome is at least not
eventually going to play all that bigger
part in the panel of anti-aging
therapies that
we'll have largely because the
microbiome consists of bacteria which
are of course what my codes which are of
course dividing cells and dividing cells
are very very much more malleable in
terms of the population structure in
terms of what they do in terms of how
they behave than anything else so my
expectation my strong expectation though
it's only a I could be wrong is that
when we fix up all the rest of the body
the human self then the microbiome will
come right to the extent that it needs
to back to democratize these treatments
right now we know that most populations
can't afford what you're talking about
what's your vision there yeah this is
very important I only briefly alluded to
it earlier good question the situation
that we have today with high-tech
medicine for the elderly should not be
viewed at a precedent so I want to
expand why shouldn't and here I am not
specifically singling out the USA here
you might expect me to because I come
from that far off place called the rest
of the world of which you know not very
much but but this is not really a public
private health care dichotomy yes it's
probably worse the lack of access of of
poorer people to do high-tech expensive
drugs but it's still a problem
everywhere so I don't want to get into
that clinic it's not the main part of
the problem the main part of the problem
is that today's high-tech health care
for the elderly doesn't work which means
that the economic arithmetic isn't there
what you have is very expensive
medicines that if you're lucky will keep
someone alive for a little bit longer in
a poor state of health consuming a lot
of money there my down the drain for
very little game now that means a bunch
of things one big thing it means is that
the electorate
or value of subsidizing that medicine
it's not very great you know people
can't really get there know get their
heads around the idea that it might be
useful to spend a lot of money keeping
people who are already sick and staying
sex alive for a little longer you know
so now consider a situation in which the
medicines do actually work what have you
got here you've got no sense that can
take people who are sick or going to be
sick very soon happen they're not sick
anymore they're not good never sick what
does it mean well first thing it means
is you don't have to give them all the
medicines that you would have had to
give them if they were sick you're only
giving the register and yes that cost my
two but we all know prevention is better
than cure and better often to me and
economically better second thing is the
kids are the elderly are gonna be more
productive because they're not having to
look after their sick parents and the
third and biggest thing of all is the
elderly themselves aren't gonna be able
bond until they're gonna be in a
position to continue to contribute
wealth Society so the entire economy the
entire population is gonna be enormous
Lee more prosperous if people have these
therapies than if they don't
putting it the other way around it would
be economically completely suicidal for
any country however ideologically
screwed up to UM to deny these therapies
to people on the best of ability to pay
you know it would be the only real
precedent that we have today that can be
applied it's not a particularly good one
but it's a hell of a lot better than
today's high-tech medicine is basic
education basic education is free even
here I mean to basic yes but it's still
free right right and the reason it's
free though at the same thing if it were
not been 20 years down the road you're
going to bankrupt and if you wouldn't
ever like to get it work for us and I
mean there are very few people
who are arguing and they don't get
anybody for basic education not to be
universally free so that is the right
precedent to be looking at right now now
of course there's a whole bunch of other
corollary of all of that for example how
would the medical industry work medical
entry today runs entirely oh very
largely on keeping sick people alive
right so it sounds like this would
completely destroy their business model
but that is very short-sighted that's
not really true at the end of the day
making medicine is preventative is the
same business involve the same skills as
making medicines of treatment no it's
the same companies that make most
medicines also make statins
they also make 18 if it is you know
these are preventative medicines and
that's an easy shift to make as and when
public opinion and public policy shifts
in a more progressive direction in
regard to the problem the health
problems of old age because it can
because the therapist would have
developed other one that occurs the
medical industry will simply follow the
money and they will do so perfectly
willingly it from the first moment that
I can get your rejuvenation therapy to
the moment that the poorest people in
the world can get rejuvenation therapy
work how long is that about a week I
mean really people people are going to
be ready the who what I was saying
earlier about me being really you know
desperate to talk to policy makers and
opinion formers the shift of public
opinion is going to be seismic and it's
gonna be extraordinarily sudden but
whether or not that shift is as
turbulent if it's in danger of being it
will predate the arrival of the
medicines by at least a decade and that
means that one way or another turbulent
or otherwise it will have all shaken
down by the time the medicines come a
lot so for sure and the medicines will
be available to everybody pretty much
the day but they're available to anybody
can I ask my question now I'm yes I'm
here I to elaborate on the last question
I respectfully disagree with you we've
known about social determinants of
health since 1977 we've known about the
impact that education has on health care
and the I just keep thinking that this
is going to be viewed as experimental
health insurance companies are not going
to cover this and it's gonna be a
modern-day version of the purge where
it's only the wealthy that will have
access to this and I just simply do not
see how one week time is going to allow
people that don't have the resources to
have this we're seeing time and time
again the health inequities that are
have happening in our country with race
and poverty it's everywhere and here in
San Francisco we see it on the streets
and I just I don't understand how that
model works said that you didn't get I
was about one week I was talking about
two particular weeks ten years apart
the week in which people get the idea is
it going to happen and the bit of the
week in which it becomes available right
but you're quite right I mean I'm
certainly not trying to say that
suddenly society will become more
egalitarian across the board absolutely
not
you know I'm quite sure that's not going
to happen
but we've got various drivers there is
the humanitarian level which are not
regarding as dominant because ultimately
the lack of humanitarian thinking is
precisely what drives the lack of
universality of access of anything right
the electoral level that is you know
like it or not we do have a gala Terry
didn't win against a number of votes
okay and at the most important level is
the pure mercenary economic plight the
fact of prosperity now you know some
prominent politicians these days make
some pretty bad mistakes when it comes
to that kind of thing but the fact is
that there's only so many mistakes you
can make before you know we get elected
and the that's gonna be this time to
think it through to shake it down not
just think it about debating you know
where the merits just economic benefit
merits of making these things available
will be debated and discussed and even
to the extent that electoral imperative
can be discounted which I don't think
again the economic imperative to ensure
that one is making these things as
available to everybody who's old enough
to need them as other countries are will
be completely irresistible
thank you you've had a lot to say about
big picture when this all works out
really well this is how our society will
grasp it maybe because I'm a physician
myself I treat a lot of people who are
younger than 50 I treat women with
breast cancer who are in their 30s and I
hopefully for the most part are actually
helping them beat their cancer disease
isn't just for people over 50 it would
help me as a skeptic too a lot of what
you've said I'm not curmudgeonly but it
would help me to hear a few more
specifics something that's tangible as
to what you really are doing right now I
understand that there are some great
companies that are potentially about to
put something into trials but if you
could just give some more specifics to
help me trust you okay so medical
conferences who audience with mainly MDS
and quite difficult because you know the
best way in the world MDS you know have
their hands full with the stuff that is
already available and they'll worry
about stuff that's coming down the pike
when it comes down the pike attentive
audience to what I have to say but I
mean you understand I'm sure that
everything that you prescribe to anybody
came from research you know there's a
process there the question is are the
kinds of things that people like me are
developing are they likely to deliver
the kind of promise that I'm describing
that's essentially your question now of
course we don't know the time frames as
I mentioned earlier respond to your
questions beginning
you know the timeframe for developing
all of this - the point of availability
is you know I feel I have a
responsibility to give a 50/50
prediction of 20 years but I always
count that in the context of the fact
that it could be hundred years with at
least 10 percent probability sure now in
terms of specifics well I mean of course
I did talk about a few of the examples
especially these cases of you know
menteng the catabolic capacity of self
by using enzymes from bacteria this is
something that we've done very well with
we've done about if immunotherapy
against amyloidosis in the heart we've
we actually as I think I mentioned don't
do much stem cells our people could we
don't need to because all the important
things are being done by other people I
think three or four stem cell therapies
for Parkinson's disease happening right
now that's probably that kind of poster
child of an aspect of aging that is
mainly driven by cell loss so it's very
important as a concept for the broader
category and so on yeah I mean like but
yeah I mean the specific we're not sure
the specifics I think really the only
basis for any skepticism is the fact
that these are early stage and obviously
the reason why there is a clinical trial
process is because things do fail at
each stage of clinical trials so we
don't know what's going to happen but if
anything gets even you know to the
beginning of the clinical trial process
that certainly means that the concept
has a lot of validity in that
you know it's the same situates the same
level of expectation cautious but you
know realistic expectation that any
researcher would have you know yes it's
a very broad well it's not just one big
step that's the point it's a whole bunch
of relatively small steps each
individual component of this it's just
like any other research program in
medical in medicine it shouldn't be
viewed as qualitatively different
because it just isn't the earth is
qualitatively different is the
juxtaposition the union of these things
that will give rise to something that is
much bigger than the sum of its parts
let's come yeah we you head of your head
first Thanks I am NOT a physician but I
do date one and I am have been just in
some of the podcasts I listen to have
been noticing a bit of talk about rampa
myosin and the inhibition of mTOR and
I'm wondering if you could talk just
wondering what your thoughts are on that
and sort of a any sort of small molecule
strategy that I may have missed when I
was looking at your talks but it didn't
seem to figure into the seven strategies
okay so rapamycin not reppin my oath in
doing what I say and what we do that is
because they basically don't seem to be
very promising in terms of making big
differences to what we don't because
they don't do rejuvenation they don't do
damage repair they do slowing down the
creation of damage rapamycin is probably
the best of the classical examples of
were often called calorie restriction
pneumatics so these are molecules that
essentially trick the body into thinking
that it's not getting enough calories
when he is now it's been known since the
1930s that if a mouse or a rat actually
doesn't get as many calories as it would
like longer than normal
quite a lot longer like 30 40 percent
longer which is awesome and sure enough
it's been it's been a very welfare for
nominal ever since caloric restriction
yep unfortunately it has been very
obvious though it has been scandalously
swept under the carpet by people who
fund their own each others grant
applications it's been very obvious for
a very very long time that longer lived
species
less benefit from calorie restriction
van socialist species if you're really
sure this thing is like a nematode worm
you can not play your lifespan by a
factor of like five by calorie
restriction done just right you can't do
that if you're a mouse you can get one
half take that unfortunately we're not
nice either you know dogs done that ten
percent monkeys a couple of percent if
you're lucky you know no good
furthermore this actually makes
evolutionary sense it's fairly
straightforward to explain why this
correlation would exist this inverse
correlation simply on the basis passed
long famines in real in the real world
in nature are much less common than
short famine so the Selective pressure
is that um what was me wouldn't mean for
drugs like rapamycin well unfortunately
it means quite a lot because what it
means to be a memetic it is that you
activate the same genetic pathways the
same gene expression changes that would
occur in the context of the real thing
which means that there is no way in hell
and nobody would dispute this there is
no way in hell that a color restriction
mimetic will ever be able to elicit a
stronger response than the real thing
sorry chicken itself and since that
stronger response is it since that
response in humans is tiny if anything I
mean obviously the clinical trial I
haven't been done but in monkeys
definitely tiny then yeah we can't
really look for much now I do want to
qualify what I just said because the
fact is calorie restriction even in
species longer species that don't gain
much content of lifespan they do gain
quite a bit in terms of healthy lifespan
it's just kind of square the health
curve you stay healthy longer you're
kind of remain more resilient to the
slings and arrows of outrageous fortune
so that's probably true in humans as
well and for that reason I am certainly
very supportive of the efforts that have
been made to develop drugs including
ones
to make money either which they can't
make out of wrapper my think it was it's
a natural product you know you know
that's all guys what is important to me
though is that people should not get an
excessive idea of how much they can do
against a sense of proportion thing this
is not the Holy Grail it is good for you
probably but it is definitely not the
ultimate solution I've been fascinated
by the Mexican salamander that can
regenerate itself and I just wonder how
like if you have a net phibian that gets
his you know hand cut off and it regrows
but it's very fascinating to me because
every part of its body it because it's
in an embryonic state right so
gerontologists has paid a lot of
attention to the regenerative capacity
of lower animals for a long time because
that has been recognized that there's a
lot of potential mechanistic overlap you
know at the end of the day the body on
the human body only keeps going as long
as it does because we have a lot of
inbuilt
mechanisms for damage repaired repairing
damage ever happens so that it doesn't
accumulate so you know one might kind of
look at these two sides of the same coin
way that but the the process of
regeneration is happens at the molecular
level at the soul level at the
anatomical level and maybe it's all part
of the same thing and sure enough we do
also find that lower animals can often
live longer depending on how you treat
them then you would expect so absolutely
it's a very important area and the
question is can we exploit it well
probably the second place I work my
primary affiliation as you've heard is
since we first foundation this
Mountain View the other place I work
part time is Ajax which is a company
based on our meter run by a guy named
Mike Wesley well my big heroes in this
field really the pioneer of doing proper
anti-aging work in the private sector
and I work in Ajax
it's mainly focused on this kind of
thing we are interested in using stem
cell therapies and other well stem cells
stimulators to enhance regeneration in
the context of aging a lot of the
information that we better work on does
come from organisms like this however I
do want to emphasize a enormous amount
that's not understood about this we
would love to be able to get our heads
around it but it's not just one thing
the way telomerase was yes as the man on
the bleeding edge of anti-aging what do
you do personally I got this question
more often than I would like so so the
fact is you should do as I say not as I
do
they for two reasons number one I'm
really well built I'm just really lucky
whether dynamically or epigenetically
you know I've been able to get tested
really high-end tests of my biological
age over the past 15 years five times
now I think and I always come out
ridiculously younger than I actually am
I'm 55 no I am I seem to be able to eat
and look exactly alike and nothing
happens I don't even need to do much
exercise so that's pretty good which
means of course that you know what the
way I live my life should not be a
recommendation to people who are less
lucky than me the second thing is that
because of my job I am NOT getting far
less sleep than I thought to have and
that's definitely bad for me
do that yep right back here and we got a
mic come in so I really appreciate your
work since the 90s of course I go back
to the 80s and doing this stuff with pro
athletes Navy SEALs internationally with
doctors and doing fun stuff like that
and so I've been pulling my hair out for
a long time trying to figure all this
out and so my question directed towards
you is not too dissimilar from his in
that I spend most of my time in the
fitness world fighting fad diets 80% fat
20% high-quality protein or vice versa
and I think we can have an understanding
if they're detrimental effects towards
lipo fussen and protein carbonyls and
superoxide dismutase and all these
wonderful things that you talked about
in your books that we understand in
research so how would you explain what
an optimal diet would be for humans all
right I'm gonna put this in very simple
terms because I the audience
a lot of people think the diet matters a
lot in aging and they think it's for
reasons that are both true and not true
and the reason they have this kind of
you know Schrodinger kind of opinion is
that over simplifying the question for
sure and this sounds like it's very much
part of your professional life it's very
easy to shorten one's life quite
significantly by a really bad lifestyle
including diet but that's not really
relevant here we should not be dividing
the population into two categories the
people who do things right and people do
things wrong instead what we should be
doing is dividing them into three
categories people do things wrong people
who do things
the way their mother said but that's all
they care about they don't try and look
out for anything clever and people who
really pay attention to the now they do
their very best to you know they get the
extreme the reason it's important to
divide into those three categories is
because the difference between the bad
category and the what your mum said
category is quite large whereas it seems
that the difference between the what
your mom said category and the optimum
category is tiny when I was talking
about the impact the benefit of calorie
restriction across species that would
what I was talking about in the early
tooth 2010 about five years ago two very
important studies published which were
reports on studies that had been going
on for more than 20 years on calorie
restriction in monkeys and to a large
extent the studies were replicated of
each other they were doing the same kind
of species of monkey and there were
differences in terms of like the range
of Ages of the monkeys and so on but not
very much though but nice large studies
done by very very very reputable people
with lots of money obviously and they
got ostensively rather differently so
essentially if you just read the
headlines one of the studies said carry
certain works and the other ones that it
doesn't but if you look closely it was
all about what I was just saying because
it looked as though work was using a
rather poor diet for the I mean of
course the color restriction is all
about the quantity of food not the
composition right so of course in both
experiments the composition of food with
the controls versus that they restricted
animals was the same it was just that
the quantity was different but in one
study further with you was a rather
refined not terribly good diet and the
other study was much more like what you
would have recommended and sure enough
the study work with what you would have
recommended it was the one in which
didn't work the way in which the current
limited diet was made of bad stuff the
controls you know were rather more
diabetic and suchlike so they you know
they with the conclusion that was come
to was that actually that was a large
part of the explanation for the
disparity in the Oh in headline results
it was more than that it was also the
fact that actually they controls in the
study way didn't work were slightly
restricted so it sounded like they were
there was an added confounder and you
know if you look at all this view you
know you had complete 20/20 hindsight
you would say what the [ __ ] why are they
do the experiments so badly but you can
say that about absolutely every
scientific experiment that's ever been
done because the fact is that's why we
do experiments Einstein said you know if
if we understood what we were doing it
wouldn't be called research so you can't
you can't blame the experimenters no
they just as they went along but the
fact is yes yeah that's probably the
single best experimental example of what
I'm saying that you have to you know
consider what they can't default middle
ground is of just doing what you want in
another question back here behind you
can you say more about the clinical
trials like what they are what exactly
is happening with humans and we're okay
at the moment out of the seven types of
treatment that I think we're going to
need the ones that's been moving towards
clinical trials the most rapidly across
the board is undoubtedly stem cell
therapy and the work that's been going
on in Parkinson's disease probably the
farthest along the first so the first
attempt to use stem cells against
Parkinson's was done more than 25 years
ago now and it was done at the point
where we we bugger-all about how to do
stem cell therapies and so sure enough
it didn't work very well but it worked
well enough occasionally just by kind of
fluke really so that eventually and now
we know so much more about how to
control what we're doing with stem cell
therapy every very much more optimistic
so I said there were several calls going
on right now there are other trials
going on stem cell therapies for other
things but that's really the way you
should be paying attention to because
it's the one that's most classically you
know a damage repair approach very often
with stem cells what you're doing is not
actually the sense thing you're not
actually trying to replace the cells
that the body is paying to replace
rather you're introducing stem cells
that will secrete stuff that will be
generally you know give a good vibe to
the cells around them
which is kind of a thing um the next one
that's gone a long way is getting rid of
molecular garbage I mentioned this
earlier on but the molecular garbage
where things have gone farthest in the
clinic is actually garbage outside the
cell which we classify as a separate
category the reason we do so is because
it is treated in a different way the way
you treat this stuff if you just
basically you cause the immune system to
engulf it and that works because once
it's inside cells then it gets destroyed
much more easily there are variations on
that theme but that's the essential idea
and that's now completely done people
have figured
away ways to use the immune system to
eliminate this stuff it's called amyloid
you've probably heard of amyloid in the
brain and also disease there are other
types of our Molloy and other types of
or in other organs in different aspects
of Aging we know how to do that now now
in Alzheimer's disease the results in
terms of clinical intervention have been
rather underwhelming in fact they've
been basically zero but we should not be
surprised by that at all nor indeed
discouraged because Alzheimer's of
course is a very complicated disease
with many other factors in addition to
amyloid so you know the rest of aging
you would expect to have to fix
everything in order to see a big effect
and we can only fix that so far but
there's other stuff well so senescence
cells so cells that get into a point
into the state where they are secreting
toxic stuff they're doing more harm than
good and the body would like to get rid
of them before whatever reason they are
resisting the body's effort to get
effort to kill them off so drugs have
been developed now that are the first
step towards getting rid of these cells
they work all that well but they work
well enough that the company that
sparing them is now ready now valued at
over a billion dollars you know a
technology based over here in San
Francisco and other companies are coming
along kind of do things in a more
sophisticated way again clinical trials
you know gonna happen this year so I'm
told that's the word on the street the
stuff I mentioned about macular
degeneration for eliminating the garbage
that kills the self at the back of the
retina that is again going to be in
clinical trial within a year that's when
I last been a house so yeah I mean it's
all going pretty well good I'm sorry
it's hard harsh well that's why start ok
there's loads of things that go wrong
with the heart in old age first of all
those asteroids chlorosis so that's the
accumulation of fatty deposits in the
artery in the world for the major
arteries that's actually something I did
mention earlier and yeah it's close to
clinical trials this idea of using
bacterial enzyme
to eliminate the oxidized cholesterol
you know again it's it's it's moving
along pretty much in the same way that
the macular degeneration one is and I
believe it's I think a year or two
maximum from clinical trial then
[Music]
arteriosclerosis the stiffening of the
arteries caused by molecular changes
that happen to the extracellular matrix
this lattice of proteins that gives the
arteries their elasticity so that's
something that again we have made a huge
breakthrough in work we funded at Yale
University that's just moving into the
private sector right now it's gonna be
our next spin out in their next month or
two and I think that's also getting
fairly close we've got very good kind of
I would say probably another year or two
in addition so maybe three or four years
out but yeah we're definitely getting
there then the drama why do fit so this
one's quite big so we could be getting
there within a year or two this is again
a work that's of work we find it so I
just mentioned amyloid in the brain that
well it's already been done it's very
clinical trials everybody established it
can be done we developed or we funded
the development of a youth of a rather
different way of using the immune system
to get rid of amyloid which essentially
involved antibodies that chop up the
analyte rather than just engulfed in it
and that works really well we publish
the proof-of-concept papers for years
ago now that's also been spun out into a
company and it really ought to be in
clinical trial within a couple of years
there are other approaches to getting
rid of this amyloid which which in the
heart which are already in clinical
trials I don't think they're going to
work so well but again that's working
well and then the final type of heart
problem that people often neglect would
be something I really want to have
worked on and I haven't been able to
make this happen yet but I go it ought
to happen fear in the stem cell thing so
there's a particular type of sound the
heart called a pacemaker cell which is
involved in essentially communicating
the signal from the brain to the heart
that says please beat and if you've got
if you're extraordinarily old
and nothing else has gone wrong with
your heart it stopped anyway look if
these cells die off they're not replaced
and eventually the brain just can't get
the can't get the signal food if they
please be so so we will replace
ourselves again you know something that
really ought to be pretty careful we've
just emcell therapy alright that was a
very solid and diverse Q&A session as
well really great hey we'll we'll wrap
up and then you guys can ask our
questions for the last couple of minutes
before he has to bounce you know I want
to thank the battery and thank you all
for coming out this has been really fun
you guys have a good time you can reach
out to Aubree Aubree Aubree at cents org
Sen s org also you can follow simulation
simulation series comm you can find our
live events there as well as all of our
other multidisciplinary videos that we
host thanks for coming out and it's the
ground and chat a little more thank you
thank you